[Music]
you're welcome to it though you've got
to go
one long cold trip
clyde tombow discovery of pluto
the 19th of january 2006
the new horizons interplanetary space
probe took off from the surface of our
earth on board an atlas v
rocket just a year later the spacecraft
performed a gravity boost maneuver near
jupiter
which helped it along to reach its final
destination
nine years after that the space probe
reached the end of its planned route
and on the 14th of july 2015 new
horizons flew by the largest dwarf
planet
ever discovered in the solar system
pluto
beaming back several thousand images of
this celestial body
and its moons
[Music]
what objectives were the scientists
planning to reach as a result of this
elaborate mission
and what was the last thing the new
horizons space probe saw
on pluto
[Music]
cosmo the first in outer space
pluto is the largest transneptunian
object in the solar system
it is also the largest object in the
kuiper belt
just like most bodies in that region of
space pluto is mostly made up of rock
and dice
and its mass is relatively small
approximately 0.22 percent that of the
earth
just to get a slightly broader picture
let's compare pluto with the moon
pluto's mass is about six times smaller
and its volume is about three times
smaller pluto's total area is 17.7
million square kilometers
and we're briefly back to earth again to
compare it with the area of russia
the largest country in the world which
is slightly smaller
17.1 million square kilometers
as for pluto's diameter it reaches
2376.6 kilometers
which is 1097.6 kilometers less than
that of the moon
as for pluto's atmosphere it is for the
most part comprised of gases evaporating
from the ice on its surface
today we know that its chief component
is nitrogen
apart from that two other gases are
methane and carbon monoxide
under the influence of high-energy
cosmic radiation
other more complex compounds form from
these elements
on account of pluto's surface
temperature these compounds are not
volatile
ethane ethylene and acetylene there are
also the so-called
tholins on settling on the dwarf
planet's surface
they have a peculiar property of giving
it a brownish hue
the average surface temperature on pluto
is 50 kelvin
that is 223.15 degrees
celsius below zero with every kilometer
higher
up this indicator increases by
approximately 7 degrees
and so the atmospheric temperature is 40
degrees
higher than that on the surface this
could be accounted for by the greenhouse
effect
caused by methane
we're used to thinking that pluto's
orbit is stable and unwavering
however on closer observation it
transpired that pluto's movement is
rather chaotic
and can be defined in non-linear
equations
it takes a lot of observation to be able
to detect that
when carried out in short time spans
observations reveal seemingly regular
movement
in reality pluto's orbit slightly shifts
in every period eventually changes to
such a point that it is impossible to
retrace its initial
trajectory this dwarf's planet's
rotation is quite peculiar too
namely it is retrograde which is also
the case for both venus
and uranus it means that they rotate in
the direction
opposite to that of the other planets
around the sun
a day on pluto lasts 6.4 earth days
due to its remoteness and small mass
pluto is a rather challenging celestial
object to study
even very big telescopes show it to us
is a tiny spot
seemingly not much different from a
regular star
we have been able to acquire a certain
amount of data with the help of the
hubble space telescope
nevertheless the greatest and most
important portion of information was
made available
after the launch of the new horizons
mission
the first photo of pluto was made back
in september 2006
when the space probe was testing its
lori camera
as the spacecraft approached pluto
closer and closer
more and more features of this dwarf
planet were revealed to us
thus the object's surface was seen to be
far from homogeneous
albedo that is diffuse reflection
properties of the surface
varies from ten to seventy percent
depending on the area of the object
which makes pluto the second object in
the solar system
after iapetus in terms of contrast in
albedo
this diversity causes periodic
variations in pluto's luminosity
and spectre as it rotates
the dwarf planet's interior must be made
up of 50 to 70 percent of rock
and 30 to 50 percent of ice its dense
rocky core must be embedded in an icy
mantle about
300 kilometers thick
according to spectral data there is
water ice on pluto's surface as well
but it is mostly camouflaged by a layer
of more volatile ices
there is also frozen methane and carbon
monoxide
as well as traces of other compounds
generally forming with methane and
nitrogen
when exposed to powerful radiation
in particular these are ethane nitriles
and phthalins which make pluto look
brownish
on the 15th of july 2015 the new
horizons space probe
flew by pluto 12 and a half thousand
kilometers away
from its surface both sides of the dwarf
planet were photographed during the
flyby
the one to be seen on closest approach
and the opposite one
thanks to these images a vast
heart-shaped area
measuring eighteen hundred by fifteen
hundred kilometers was identified
it was later nicknamed pluto's heart or
tombow reggio
the left part of this area is believed
to be a crater filled with crystal
nitrogen
also two mountain ranges were identified
in this area
the height of the first reaches 3500
meters
and it was given the name the tenzing
montes
the height of the second one dubbed the
hillary montes
reaches up to 1 500 meters
the most notable geological object found
on pluto
is sputnik planitia this trench is
likely to be an impact crater with a
diameter measuring one thousand
four hundred and ninety two kilometers
sputnik planitia is filled with frozen
gases
and is streaked with a great number of
grooves which divided into irregular
cell-like areas measuring dozens of
kilometers
there may also be cryo-volcanism on
pluto
the last image taken by the spacecraft
looks to be indicative of just
that the potential cryo volcano that can
be seen in this picture
was dubbed right mons the surface in the
picture is comparatively young by space
standards
and practically devoid of impact craters
this
shows that the crust in this area was
formed relatively recently
and if right mons really is a cryo
volcano
its enormous size of 144 kilometers
across and four kilometers high
easily makes it the largest cryo volcano
in the outer area of the solar system
among other interesting features
discovered by new horizons
there is a blue stratified haze
enveloping the whole of the dwarf
planet in the images the haze is seen to
reach over 200 kilometers high
and is registered by the ultraviolet
spectrometer to persist to the point of
300 kilometers above the surface
the haze is likely to be made up of
particles of non-volatile elements that
originate from atmospheric gases
the ones i've already spoken about these
elements gradually settle on the dwarf
planet's surface
and that is the way this effect is
produced
the new horizons mission is scheduled to
continue until
2026 apart from studying the objects in
the pluto system
the spacecraft has already provided
insights into other kuiper belt objects
too
and even though its fuel supply is
insufficient for a dramatic change of
course
the radio isotope generator's energy
should be enough to last it for another
10 years
immediately after the space probe had
flown by pluto
astronomers used the hubble telescope to
look around for other objects that could
be observed within the framework of the
mission
the first of them ultimatuly is a binary
asteroid in the kuiper belt
whose two components diameters measure
19 and 14 kilometers
it was closely passed by new horizons on
the 1st of january 2019
another object was the asteroid 2014
pn 70 measuring 40 kilometers across
it was passed by the probe in march
2019.
excitingly apart from that having
traveled 8 billion kilometers away from
the earth
new horizons reached a great vantage
point for better observation of the
stars closest to the sun
proxima centauri and wolf 359
in april 2020 the spacecraft was also
used for double-checking the distance to
these stars
apart from the objectives mentioned this
amazing mission
stands a good chance of being able to
reach quite a few more in the future
while the spacecraft keeps beaming back
new images to the earth we will be able
to conduct research based on the photos
of the celestial bodies it has already
passed
for example the pictures of pluto's
largest moon
charon taken on their brief encounter
with a space probe
if you'd like to hear more about this
space object in later videos
let us know in the comments or just hit
the like button under this video
and then very soon we will set out on
another fascinating journey to the realm
of this dwarf planet let's keep in touch
[Music]
you